[Music]
you told me before the season ever
started that you did not see yourself
getting intimate with everyone in
fantasy suites do you see yourself
getting intimate with everybody in
fantasy suites what do you think your
approach to them will be right as I
stand here today no but when you get to
that moment you just don't know you know
I don't see that happening for me as I
stand here today what can you tell us
about that that I held true to my word
yes okay okay I'm a woman of my word do
you get intimate with anyone I don't
know I didn't give you all that I just
do how do fantasy suites affect the
decisions that you make Oh
fantasy suites were huge for me like I
walked into fantasy suites with a list
of like questions that I had cuz you
know you can't cover everything in the
limited amount of time you have so it's
the first time you have extended time
with this person and so for me it's like
if I'm taking the next step I got a list
of questions fantasy suites were a game
changer for me okay it's and it's your
first off-camera time right right right
so do you ask those questions off camera
or on both okay I ask them both but I
needed to see if the person is the same
off-camera that they are on camera you
know you never know was there anybody
who wasn't the same on camera as they
were off camera no they were all okay
[Music]